[Music]
in thought he was slick news submitted
by favorite pizza pineapple mushroom a
messenger [ __ ] for reals
yes pineapple machine so much I'm
willing talk have you ever tried that is
about Niki is that everywhere we go if
somebody where's Pete so we have to
order a whole [ __ ] pineapple don't I
say we get it half because she can't
bend her [ __ ] pizza rule for one
night
no I just saw are you willing to try
that new Kiwi on pizza trend oh they
have Kiwi I'm okay I mean I would try
anything but I guess it's not that far
off from queuing yes it is Kiwis sour
and it tastes like it's all know the
pineapples sweet girl look at that shoe
but it goes in the oven all the sugars
come out because the water gets a bit
about the Kiwi you don't know you're
right that's why we're try it that's why
we try it
[ __ ] eBay we try it at least once
even like Hawaiian I could tell you why
I don't like it if at least I try it did
you ever just do a pineapple pizza so
that everyone doesn't have just
something always done honey I'm not
really that into pizza first of all so
we all suffer yeah
a passenger claims an American Airlines
employee stalked her and sent over 100
unsolicited texts she was horny she's
probably morning or he know her stalked
her he does it say how horny she was you
thought you read this or has they all
flight attendants are females in there
no no no you know what I pictured I did
encounter a very horny thirsty flight
attendant that was after one of my
friends during a tour all night you know
I'm sorry but you had to point that out
why we were each other because you're a
[ __ ] well let's continue no no I remind
it reminded me of that so then I thought
about that story thanks yeah dude how do
you know she was morning thirsty what
was she doing
because during the show I was so we were
onto her right not hit after you ended I
forgot the number she kept hitting him
up after the I guess we landed she even
got in a regular clothes and went to the
show and she wanted to hang out with
them and all that and we
leaving right after the show no why did
she ruin it by getting in her regular
clothes
we're all just watching no but the whole
attraction of [ __ ] a flight attendant
is that she would have the outfit on oh
I don't know what the conversation is I
don't know anyway let me talk about this
one so actually she was boarding she was
in a boarding area at the San Diego
International Airport waiting her
Chicago bound flights when all of a
sudden oh this is what she looks like
with all the bus I did days actually is
what she looks like
not flight attendant the yes yes the one
that got thirsted on exactly
so she received this text so who would
you like to be the creeper the creep
I'll be the creeper and I'm surprised a
flight attendant wasn't gay hey thanks
to Joe would you just show me the
picture I just I saw her it I was like
okay that's the horny girl Wow no she's
the victim here you can't do the show
without them honestly we could boo man
you shouldn't we better show is that the
flight attendant no no exit keep me let
me clear things up for those of you that
are confused the footage just showed is
of Ashley who's the victim here she
received text messages let solicited
text messages from an employee at
American Airlines you don't know yet if
this is I made it better flight
attendant that's why everyone thought it
was a flight attendant
tip those text messages got her horny
[Laughter]
Nikki will play The Creeper and now only
Ashley ready hey Ashley oh how are you
I'm good thank you
sorry I'm not sure who this is I met you
the other day at the airport Wilhelm Oh
Creed nope by the way I must tell you
that you are gorgeous you I think you
didn't remember me I work for the
airline thank you so much smiley face
emoji you work for the air and she
[ __ ] up weird airline she gave it
emoji oh and then they continue a
conversation and then she asks so I gave
you my number
what Airport oh because he ended up
saying that she gave him her number but
she was like I gave you my number what
Airport
tell me otherwise the phone is not going
to work once we airborne will you join
me I have two seats open next to me I
gave you my number
honestly I got it from your bag tag Oh
God you that's what I thought I really
like you
which out port can we know about each
other San Diego she's getting wet
nowadays this will come join me come on
join me yes lol not okay
not cool I have two seats open next to
me good for you I will be interesting in
the flight everything else what I told
you is true leave me alone okay it's up
to you but friendship with me will be
very beneficial to you I can always give
you good seats access to lounges and
free flights to you can't think about it
these all have exclamation points but if
it's still a No
that's up to you I will not bother you
again but at least give me one a one
chance to prove myself dude they usually
say friends with benefits this guy's got
a [ __ ] watch that's a lot better
bullet point benefits there's something
called a buddy pass that she could get
to flying on standby all the time he's
got very broken English - I feel like I
get DMS from these type of people all
the time that like they don't see like
wait this is only benefiting you like
how can you not be interested in this or
respond to the English no no I just get
I'll give you a cell phone if you have
sex with going like that they're like we
do you understand the offer it's like I
don't it's a free self okay okay 20
goats now
final offer 20 goats no I will give you
money for your feet like do not
understand are you stupid
much money I have lots of money do you
understand though are you doing I guess
like dogs I guess you don't get it
clearly you know would you do it for
like John the beginning of the story yes
I watch cell phones and lounge access
yeah yeah all right so anyway he ended
up oh I just got dated ever anyway so he
was telling her like you guess when they
were talking about she was trying to
figure out when did she give him her
number so then he ends up saying I just
saw you at the airport again you all
you're all new very gorgeous in great
top today she's so wet yeah so she was
wearing a grey shirt he's warming up and
so she started getting scared obviously
but then she's I get it she finds out
that this phone is in her flight to open
seats no yeah lucky her she gets all the
benefits right better there you can move
yeah I like he had a rear sight no I had
two open seats I'm interesting very
interesting it would have changed if he
sent two selfie no so what ended up
happening was no Giada think so no
unless he looks like Jason boom did you
get the picture of my penis did you see
it
do I need to send it again they call but
that was my penis do you think it's not
my penis because it is put my face in it
I promise you my piece will be very
interested yeah so when they're on the
flight she finds out or like he's
telling her that she please on row like
he's in row 15 and then he saw her walk
by no and he's texting her there and so
she got really freaked out so did she
she called the flight attendant she was
crying she was like those and this guy
stopped me he's ahead I don't know what
he what he looks like I don't know who
he is
oh dude find out he's like he's like
do but honestly the guy from eel could
get it
no really anything so yeah I think he's
got some I told you I think he's got
some charm to him I would think I would
fall for it I'm like he's got some
smooth talking skills his stalker is
stalker that ever stop like the survive
everything else no mysterious vibe what
is this I already know what does he
could get at me and that means you like
yeah yeah like if I was a character I
show [ __ ] this man not me in the show I
hate this revelation I get where the
girls will fall for him ya [ __ ] [ __ ] up
I liked it I liked in the beginning of
this video when I didn't know this and
we were just calling this chick horny no
she didn't say he could get it or
nothing I get that he's charming some
[ __ ] yeah he's literally her saying he
could get it are you small vagina blast
oh well no but I guess people do need to
re-explain things kiss
no but she was saying this stuff right I
meant that I would take his dick if I
was a clear all of it all [ __ ] six
seven eight nine inches I try to make
her fantasy bigger so while you simmer
in that I'm gonna continue here you
control we turn we find out that this
employers name is Ahmed and he so as
soon as they landed in Chicago
that's when security guards came and
took him away oh dude a bad boy bad boy
no well I
grocery store he's like grabbing the
bags he's like oh my dream so what ended
up happening is that when she was
sitting in the waiting area he was near
her and he looked at her luggage and
read the the tag all romantic what a
detective put a Google Voice on
Wow a Google Voice number tomorrow my
and mine faces out and then I'd like its
facing the world on the dammit I should
have lived it Google Voice number you
can't flip it I can but I think it's
just you know it's [ __ ] tedious so
once it yeah I'm just like I got to
change it for my next one okay Nikki did
the chicken the story she could get it
she looks like Delilah she looks like me
no chick in this story she could get me
the horny flight attendant alright you
go she's still thinking about him
already flight attendant all be
contacting her but this chick doesn't
like benefits obviously
yep shoot him away he doesn't happen
she's ungrateful he's not that bad yeah
so Atlanta so she was really creeped out
because after she realized that he read
her bag tag got her phone number it also
had her address on there she's actually
experienced like PTSD sort of know he
could be outside the window because you
look good in your gray top today oh
that's [ __ ] creepy she's had so this
happened in April she has had trouble
sleeping eating and so now oh so then
after all this happened with American
Airlines yes they removed him from the
flight but when she contacted them to
find out if he was still employed she
never heard anything from the airline
and so her she felt that they were being
negligent so now she's doing oh [ __ ]
that's why she's so traumatized a reason
why we now know about the story months
and months and months of trauma yes we
don't know her history that yeah it is
traumatizing what the [ __ ] I know I'm
just saying a stonker with benefits
well now I could see it coming a mile
away the lawsuit part the lawsuit part
because we can hear the case being built
through the story right and so it's like
good for her that's all for her
take it yep take it and run they did not
I hope you make millions right okay
are you being sarcastic mom you're being
serious with me she's [ __ ] wins
there's saltiest she has a case no she's
the person that gets on a car accident
at a two months later oh my neck my neck
she's like every time I look at a
vehicle now I get these phantom pains
[ __ ] all this I'm trying to find out is
he employed or not I don't want this
happening to other people on months and
months of being ignored I and she has a
case obviously she does if she's doing
him we adult attorney with a lot of
benefit stuff yeah well she could
probably get way more if she wins
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]